This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那真是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在Outer、My Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全去进行，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在出售过程中篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。Greg，一个男同性恋者，Michael Mancini。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个陌生模型中建立复原力的科学。
world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they make. for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. You know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I hope that everybody has been doing well, taking care of themselves, finding something to stay optimistic about, whatever it is that gets you up in the morning,
世界。让自己经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即TWA%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理有何影响。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。你们懂的。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。我希望每个人都过得很好，照顾好自己，找到能让自己保持乐观的东西，无论是什么让你在早晨醒来，
that gets you going. I hope you're prioritizing it. Today I have a little bit of a different episode for you for long time OG listeners of the show. You'll know that every kind of six months I like just to do a little chatty, unplanned, Q&A kind of episode, a sit down chat, I kind of get to know me, a life update. And that is what we're going to do today. I think it's been about six months since we last did one of these episodes. So there's a lot to catch up on. and a lot of epiphanies that I've kind of realized about myself recently, one of which has to do with
让你行动起来。我希望你把它放在首位。今天我为你准备了一期略有不同的节目，对于节目的长期老听众来说。你们会知道，大约每六个月我喜欢做一期闲聊的、没有计划的、Q&A式的节目，一次坐下来聊天，有点像了解我，生活更新。这就是我们今天要做的。我想距离我们上次做这种类型的节目已经大约六个月了。所以有很多事情要追溯，也有很多我最近对自己产生的顿悟，其中一个就与
the fact that if you haven't noticed, I'm a little bit ill. So these last two weeks, I've had like a really serious case of tonsillitis, which I don't know if you've ever had tonsillitis. I'm hoping that you haven't. But for those of you who have experienced this, it is like a whole body experience. I think I get it semi-regular, like probably once a year, and every time I forget what it feels like to go through. Like, it is hellish. My whole body was aching. I lost my voice, which as somebody who does podcasting full-time is like literally the worst thing ever. And it's kind of one of those hard circumstances with this job, right? Like, if you lose your voice, you can't do your job. you can't work because your main service, your main product, your vocal cords are like
这样一个事实有关：如果你还没注意到，我生病了。所以这两周，我得了一种非常严重的扁桃体炎，我不知道你有没有得过扁桃体炎。我希望你没有。但对于那些经历过的人来说，这就像是一次全身的体验。我想我大概是半规律地得这个病，可能一年一次，每次我都忘记了得病是什么感觉。就像，这简直是地狱。我全身都在酸痛。我失去了声音，作为一个全职做播客的人来说，这简直是字面意义上最糟糕的事情。这也是这份工作带来的那种艰难现实之一，对吧？如果你失去了声音，你就无法工作。你无法工作，因为你的主要服务、你的主要产品——你的声带就像是
non-operational. And so it was kind of this like weird feeling of like, oh my God, I want to be doing things. I want to be working on the podcast. I want to be putting out new episodes, but I genuinely cannot speak. And the frustrating thing was that I think I've spoken about this before. Maybe I'm just going to go ahead and spoil it. Why not? I finished my book. My book is done. and it still has a while before it comes out and goes through the editing process and all of that. But yeah, it was like a marathon when I got back from traveling at the start of the year. I'd probably only done around like 15%.
无法运转。所以这是一种很奇怪的感觉，就像，天哪，我想做事情。我想制作播客。我想发布新节目，但我真的说不出话来。最让人沮丧的是，我想我以前说过这个。也许我要直接剧透了。为什么不呢？我写完了我的书。我的书写完了。距离它出版、经过编辑流程以及所有这些还有一段时间。但是，是的，当我今年年初旅行回来时，这就像是一场马拉松。我大概只完成了15%左右。
And I was like, okay, time to like shift into gear and write this freaking manuscript. So that has been like really high in my priority list. I finished it two weeks ago. Insane. It was like probably one of the most like hardest things that I've been. ever done like in my professional and career life in terms of like sustained mental effort but here's the catch I finished the book I took a day off and then I remember you know that feeling where you can feel yourself getting sick like the back of your throat is burning and like stinging and you can't
当时我就想，好吧，是时候换挡，写完这篇该死的手稿了。所以这在我的优先级列表中一直排得很高。我两周前完成了它。太疯狂了。这可能是我职业生涯和职场生涯中做过的最艰难的事情之一，就持续的心理付出而言。但问题来了。我写完了书，休息了一天，然后我记得，那种你能感觉到自己开始生病的的感觉——你的喉咙后方在燃烧、刺痛，你甚至无法
swallow and you're just hoping that maybe you just have something like stuck in your throat you've like eaten something spicy no it was the sickness it was the illness coming on and within like two days. I was like immobilized in bed. It was great though because it gave me a chance to watch, rewatch, not watch for the first time, obviously not, but rewatch like the entire Twilight series. I think if you haven't watched those recently as an adult, you need to be doing that because I brought like a whole new critical feminist lens to that situation and to those movies that I've never had before. So I watched Twilight. I made a lot of soup in my new little Dutch oven. And I also had an epiphany about myself. Because whilst I literally felt like I was on my deathbed,
吞咽，你只是希望也许你的喉咙里卡了什么东西，你吃了什么辣的东西。不，这就是生病，是疾病正在袭来。在两天之内。我就瘫痪在床了。不过这也很棒，因为它给了我一个机会去观看、重温，不是第一次看，显然不是，而是重温整个《暮光之城》系列。我想如果你最近作为成年人没有看过这些，你需要去看看，因为我为那种情况和那些电影带来了一种全新的、批判性的女性主义视角，这是我以前从未有过。所以我看了《暮光之城》。我在我的新小荷兰锅里做了很多汤。我也对我自己有了一个顿悟。因为当我字面感觉自己就像在垂死病中时，
the one thing I couldn't stop thinking about was the fact that I wasn't being productive. That here I was with all of this empty time, this empty space that I should be filling, sitting at home, and I wasn't doing anything. I would end, like, every single evening feeling terrible. Let me say that. Like, I was not well. But the, like, resounding thought in my brain was, like, guilt. It was a sense of guilt that I hadn't gotten more done.
我满脑子想的唯一一件事就是我没有产出。我居然有所有这些空闲时间，这些我本该填满的空白时间，坐在家里，而我却什么都没做。我每天晚上结束时，都会感觉糟糕透顶。让我这么说吧。我当时真的很不好。但是，我脑海中挥之不去的声音，是内疚。是一种我没有完成更多事情的内疚感。
And that I had, you know, optimistically woken up with this, like, huge to-do list of things that would seem, like, were impossible for me to do in my state. Like, clean my entire house. write scripts for podcast episode, like finalize big project, like jump on, you know, overseas court. Like that was not possible. I couldn't speak. I couldn't like get up without feeling dizzy. So of course I wasn't moving through my to-do list as fast as I should have been. And I had an excuse right there. Like I had a really valid reason for why I wasn't able to do that. And yet I wasn't taking it. That excuse was, was not available to me. I just felt so much shame and guilt and frustration that I just finished this huge thing. I'd finished this book
而且我，你知道，原本乐观地醒来，带着一大堆待办事项清单，在我的状态下，这些事情似乎是不可能完成的。比如打扫整个房子。为播客节目写脚本，比如敲定重大项目，比如参加，你知道的，海外法庭（译注：此处连麦）。那是不可能的。我说不出话来。我站起来就会感到头晕。所以当然，我没有像应该的那样快地完成我的待办事项清单。我当时就有现成的借口。我有一个非常合理的理由，解释我为什么无法做到这一点。然而我并没有接受它。那个借口对我来说并不起作用。我只感到无比的羞耻、内疚和沮丧，因为我刚刚完成了这个巨大的事情。我完成了这本书，
that was meant to clear up so much more time for me. And this sickness that I was experiencing, this tonsillitis, that was just like a small roadblock that I had to push through. And if I wasn't able to push through it, like I must be lazy. I must be, you know, undisciplined. I must be procrastinating when in fact it is like a very valid reason to not be getting as much done. And through like conversations I was having with my friends and with my boyfriend, I was like, oh, this is not just a problem when I'm ill. This is a problem at like all stages of my life that I continually tie my worth and my sense of self to my output and how much I am able to do in each day and how hard I'm able to push myself. And I do think that I have become one of those people who like sees busyness as. a status symbol. And there was a really fascinating article in the Atlantic about this recently
它本该为我腾出更多时间。而我正在经历的这场病，这个扁桃体炎，只是我必须克服的一个小路障。如果我无法克服它，那我一定很懒。我一定，你知道的，缺乏纪律。我一定是在拖延，但事实上，这是一个非常合理的理由，说明为什么你不能完成那么多事情。通过我和朋友以及男友的对话，我发现，哦，这不仅仅是在我生病时才有的问题。这是我在我生活的各个阶段都存在的问题，我不断地将我的价值感和自我感与我的产出挂钩，与我每天能做多少事情挂钩，以及我能把自己逼得有多紧。我确实觉得我成了那种把忙碌视为地位象征的人。
that was essentially like, you know, the way that we have glorified hustle culture and the way that we have glorified and idolized success in our society and in our culture means that it's seen as impressive when we don't have boundaries, when we don't take necessary time off when we are genuinely falling apart. When we don't prioritize the things that are important to us like our wellness, like our relationships, like our free time, all of those things are seen as impressive these days. And I think that I've really been bitten by that bug. And on a deeper level, it's not just apparent when I'm unwell or when I'm sick. It's also very apparent to me now in how I operate on a daily. So for example, I was talking to my partner about this and he made this
最近《大西洋月刊》上有一篇非常迷人的文章谈到了这一点，基本上就是说，你知道，我们在社会和文化中美化奋斗文化的方式，以及我们美化和偶像化成功的方式，意味着当我们没有边界、当我们没有在真正崩溃时抽出必要的休息时间时，会被视为令人印象深刻的。当我们没有把对我们重要的事情放在首位时，比如我们的健康、我们的人际关系、我们的自由时间，所有这些事情如今都被视为令人印象深刻的。我想我真的中了这个毒。而且在更深层次上，这不仅仅在我身体不适或生病时显现。现在它在我日常的行事方式中也表现得非常明显。比如，我和伴侣谈过这件事，他提出了一个
really fascinating point. He was like even when you are having quote unquote downtime, you feel the need to be socially productive within that. So like if I have a weekend off, it's like seeing that weekend not as space to relax and not as space to be free and spontaneous. It's like, okay, we have these like quadrants. We have these time slots that I need to fill. I need to be seeing people on Saturday night. I need to be seeing people for lunch on Sunday. I need to be seeing people on Monday morning for like a brunch. Like I need to be catching up on my social life. I need to be socially productive even when I'm not being, I don't know, career
非常吸引人的观点。他说，甚至当你有所谓的停工时间时，你也会觉得需要在其中保持社交上的产出。所以，如果我有一个周末休息，我就不会把那个周末看作是放松的空间，也不把它看作是自由和随性的空间。我就觉得，好吧，我们有这些象限。我们有这些我需要填满的时间段。我需要在周六晚上见人。我需要在周日午餐时见人。我需要在周一早上见人喝个早午餐。我需要赶上我的社交生活。即使我没有进行，我不知道，职业
productive or like work life productive. And I was kind of shocked when he said that because I was like, wow, you are absolutely right. I always just thought that I just had a higher threshold for, I don't know, connection. And for seeing people, I'm such an extra. that it didn't feel, I don't know, it didn't feel odd. It didn't feel problematic to need to fill my weekends in such a way or to fill my off time in such a way because I do gain energy from seeing other people, from seeing my friends, from like hearing about their lives.
上的产出或工作生活上的产出，我也需要在社交上保持产出。当他说出这话时，我有点震惊，因为我想，哇，你说得绝对没错。我一直以为我只是对，我不知道，人际连接有更高的阈值。而且我喜欢见人，我是一个外向的人，所以这感觉不到，我不知道，这感觉不到奇怪。觉得需要这样填满周末或填满空闲时间并没有什么问题，因为我确实能从见到其他人、见到我的朋友、听到他们的生活中获得能量。
But when he pointed out, I was like, no, I approach socializing like it is a to-do list. And it's like kind of sickening. Like it was, and it's not to say like, oh my gosh, my friends are like a task that I need to check off. Or I have like an ongoing list of like, I need to see this person by this date, almost like a deadline. No, it's just more that when I see blank space in the calendar, I want it to be utilized. And if I have devoted that space to, you know, not doing work, the other way I can utilize it is by socializing. So yeah, it became kind of apparent to me that I had a problem. I think that when you are genuinely.
但当他指出来时，我心想，不，我对待社交就像对待待办事项清单一样。这让人有点反胃。这并不是说，哦天哪，我的朋友就像是我需要勾掉的任务。或者我有一个持续的列表，比如，我必须在某个日期之前见这个人，几乎就像一个截止日期。不，这更像是当我看到日历上有空白时，我希望它被利用。如果我已经把那个空间奉献给，你知道的，不工作，我利用它的另一种方式就是通过社交。所以，是的，我开始明显地感觉到我出了问题。我认为当你真正
so unwell that like I said, I couldn't get out of bed, I couldn't speak, I couldn't like go outside. And yet the first thing that I'm thinking of is how productive I'm being and what I'm contributing and what I'm getting done. Probably not a sign of a healthy relationship with work or with, you know, your sense of self-esteem or confidence when it comes to not putting things out and not being busy. And then secondly, that need for social productivity was another element and facet of this. that I don't think I'd ever been aware of before. And I kind of was like doing a little bit of investigating because I think that the big misconception I had was that I'm just an overachiever. That is who I have always been.
病得很重，正如我所说，我无法下床，我无法说话，我无法出门。然而我脑子里想的第一件事是我有多么高产，我贡献了什么，我完成了什么。当你没有产出、不忙碌时，这可能不是一个健康的迹象，说明你与工作或与你的自尊心、自信心的关系并不健康。其次，对社交产出的需求是其中的另一个元素和方面，这是我以前从未意识到的。我当时有点在做调查，因为我认为我最大的误解是我只是个过度成就者。我一直都是这样的人。
I've been somebody who is a perfectionist, somebody who is an overachiever, somebody who likes working hard. I don't need to work hard. I like it. But that was really like opening a bit of a box for me because I was like, why do I like it? Who likes working more than they like? having downtime. Who likes feeling guilty for taking a break? It's the people who tie their identity
我一直是一个完美主义者，一个过度成就者，一个喜欢努力工作的人。我不需要努力工作。我喜欢它。但这对我来说真的有点像打开了一个盒子，因为我在想：我为什么喜欢它？谁会比喜欢拥有休息时间更喜欢工作？谁会因为休息而感到内疚？正是那些将自己的身份与认同感寄托在成功感和感觉自己正在做事情上的人，并从这些感觉中获得认可。而这通常可以追溯到你在童年时期被教导要成为什么样的人。
and receive validation from feeling successful and feeling like they're doing things. And often that really ties back to how you were like who you were taught to be as a child. And when I say who you were taught to be, I mean who you were conditioned to be through praise and through feedback and through comments from your teachers and your parents and your mentors and your friends that you meet this archetype. You are the overachiever. You are good at school. You are someone who is successful. You are a hard worker.
当我说你被教导要成为什么样的人时，我的意思是，通过赞扬、反馈以及你的老师、父母、导师和朋友对你的评论，你被条件化成为这样的人，你符合这种原型。你是一个过度成就者。你擅长学校功课。你是一个成功的人。你是一个努力工作的人。
You are gifted academically. When you hear that repeated, as I think is quite a nice thing, obviously we want to like positively reinforce children and shower them with praise and make them feel good about themselves. But when everything you've heard about yourself that is good, everything you've heard about yourself, that is good. Everything you hear about yourself that makes you valuable and makes people like you is tied back to how hard you can work and how much you can excel and what you can give. It's really hard to have any nuance in terms of your personality and in terms of your identity.
你在学业上很有天赋。当你听到这些反复出现时，我认为这其实是一件挺好的事情，显然我们希望积极地强化儿童，用赞扬淹没他们，让他们对自己感觉良好。但是，当你关于自己所听到的一切美好的事情，你关于自己所听到的一切，都是好的。你所听到的一切让你变得有价值、让别人喜欢你的事情，都与你能有多努力工作、你能有多优秀以及你能付出多少挂钩。要想在你的个性和身份上拥有任何细微差别，真的是非常困难的。
Who am I beyond output? If you've never been told that you are a kind person, that you are a generous person, that you are a creative person, that you're somebody who just brings peace to their life, that prioritizes their happiness. Like those are things that we are not necessarily praised for or complimented on as children. We're complimented on how we meaningfully apply ourselves to the pursuit of success and things like grades and things like academics. And so I think the older you get, you have an opportunity to kind of release yourself from that identity. If you are somebody who has always been seen as an overachiever or like a gifted child or someone. or somebody who is a extremely hard worker.
除了产出，我是谁？如果你从来没有被告知你是一个善良的人，你是一个慷慨的人，你是一个有创造力的人，你是一个能给别人的生活带来平静、把他们的幸福放在首位的人。像这些事情，我们作为孩子时并不一定因此受到赞扬或称赞。我们受到的称赞是我们如何有意义地将自己投入到对成功的追求中，比如成绩和学术。所以我认为你年纪越大，你就有机会从这种身份中解脱出来。如果你一直被视为一个过度成就者、一个天才儿童、某人，或者是一个极其努力工作的人。
You do have an opportunity to kind of throw away that identity when you're moving through that like gaining independence phase and trying to assert yourself as, you know, independent from other people's judgments. I don't think I ever did that though. I don't think that part of my identity was ever, I never questioned it. I never saw it as unhealthy.
当你经历那种获得独立、试图宣称自己独立于他人判断的阶段时，你确实有机会抛弃这种身份。但我认为我从来没有这样做过。我觉得我身份的那一部分从来没有被质疑过。我从未认为它是不健康的。
I never saw the bad side of it. And so it's created this version of me who doesn't know when to fucking stop. Like, sorry to swear, but it's like quite frustrating to only realize that at like 24. The other component of it is that I think that I am somebody who likes to fix things. I don't like seeing that there is a problem or something that needs to be done and not in some way in some capacity working towards a solution for that problem. I know for a fact that I am somebody who doesn't,
我从未看到它的不好的一面。因此它创造了这样一个版本的我，他不知道什么时候该他妈的停下来。抱歉爆粗口，但只有在24岁时才意识到这一点，实在是相当令人沮丧。它的另一个组成部分是，我认为我是一个喜欢解决问题的人。我不喜欢看到有问题或有事情需要做，却不在某种程度上朝着解决这个问题的方向努力。我非常清楚我是一个不喜欢的人，
enjoy the mess or the clutter of an unorganized life and doesn't enjoy the sense that there are things that are nagging me in my brain that are kind of like screaming get me done get me done so there is actually a term for this i don't know if i would call it a condition but an experience in psychology and it's called the zirginic effect and it essentially refers to how for some of us the like sense of an unfinished task is incredibly difficult to overlook. It is incredibly, you know, hard to move forward or to relax when you know that there is something that you haven't completed, that you forgot about. For example, if you know you have an essay due, but you've put time aside for it next weekend, you've got a whole 12-hour period to get it done, you know that you'll get it done.
享受杂乱无章的生活所带来的凌乱或杂乱，也不喜欢大脑中有些事情在唠叨、仿佛在尖叫“把我干完吧，把我干完吧”的感觉。所以心理学上其实有一个术语，我不知道我是否会称之为一种病症，但它是一种体验，叫做“蔡格尼克记忆效应”（Zigernic effect），它本质上指的是，对于我们中的一些人来说，未完成任务的这种感觉是极其难以忽视的。当你明知有什么事情没有完成、被你遗忘了的时候，要向前迈进或放松下来是极其困难的。例如，如果你知道你有一篇论文要交，但你已经为它留出了下周末的时间，你有整整12个小时来完成它，你知道你能完成它。
You still can't help yourself or stop yourself from focusing on it in the weeks prior, in the days beforehand when you don't have the capacity to do it. You still know that it's going to be finished. You're just not working on it right now, but it lingers and you can't forget about it. For me, that's my, like, to-do list. As soon as I've put something on my to-do list, I've realized this about myself, as soon as I've, as soon as I've, like, said to myself, like, okay, I want to do this. I need to get this done.
在接下来的几周里，在之前的几天里，当你没有能力去做这件事的时候，你仍然无法控制自己不去关注它。你仍然知道它会完成的。你只是现在没有在做它，但它一直挥之不去，你无法忘记它。对我来说，那就是我的待办事项清单。一旦我把某事列入待办事项清单，我就意识到了这一点，一旦我，一旦我对自己说，好吧，我想要做这件事。我需要把这个做完。
I want to have like five or six podcast episodes like lined up. I want to be fully planned for this trip. I want to have this like whole script fact checked and done by tonight. There is no way that I can stop myself before that gets done. It's honestly a compulsion. It is like an obsession. And again, it's this zirginic effect where there is something in our brain that keeps coming back to unfinished business.
我希望有五六个播客节目排好队。我希望为这次旅行做好充分的计划。我希望今晚之前把整个剧本都核对完并做好。在那之前，我绝对无法阻止自己停下来。老实说，这是一种强迫症。这就像是一种执念。再说一次，这就是那种未完成效应，我们大脑中的某些东西会不断回到那些未完成的事情上。
I think all of these factors, all of these experiences ultimately lead back to this toxic productivity that I'm speaking about. This unyielding sense that there is always stuff that needs to be done. There is always more that can be done. And not doing it is kind of a blemish on my character and is something that I should feel ashamed for because somewhere out there, somebody is not making the same compromises as me. somebody is not taking the rest day. Somebody is not being quote unquote lazy like I am. And it's really, really unhealthy and problematic.
我认为所有这些因素，所有这些经历最终都会导致我所说的这种有毒的生产力。这种毫不妥协的感觉，即总是有事情需要做。总有更多的事情可以做。而不去做它某种程度上是我性格上的瑕疵，是我应该感到羞耻的事情，因为在某个地方，有人没有做出像我这样的妥协。有人没有休息。有人没有像我一样所谓的懒惰。这真的非常非常不健康，而且很有问题。
So in like the couple of, well, in like the week that I've realized that this is something that I kind of need to address and I'm sure it's going to take me a while to really get my thumb over it and to get control of it. But some of the things I started pondering was whether I would be as unforgiving when it came to other people in my life who were experiencing the same thing. So let me articulate that a little bit better. Obviously, me being sick gave me a reason to not be able to do all these things that I wanted to do. And that is actually super valid. That is an excellent reason to not be as productive or active in your life. But for me, personally, I am my harshest critic, as I'm sure you are your
所以在过去的几天里，或者说就在我意识到这是我需要解决的问题的这一周里，我相信我需要花一段时间才能真正掌握它并加以控制。但我开始思考的一些事情是，如果我生活中的其他人经历同样的事情，我会不会像对他们那样毫不留情。所以让我把这一点表达得更清楚一些。很明显，我生病了，这让我有理由无法做所有我想做的事情。这其实非常合理。这是一个极好的理由，让你在生活中没有那么高产或活跃。但就我个人而言，我是自己最严厉的批评者，我相信你也是你自己的
harshest critic as well. So I thought about the compassion and the care that I would show a friend who was going for this. If, you know, like my best friend Aaron was like to me, oh my gosh, and it's, it's interesting because she actually called me yesterday and she has COVID. And so I actually got to have this conversation with somebody else, the conversation that I should have been having with myself. And she said to me, she was like, I'm super sick and I just can't get anything done. I need to clean the house. Like we have visitors coming. I like need to call and sick to work. But I feel so lazy and what I said to her was that is ridiculous you have no reason to feel lazy your body is screaming at you to take a break it is telling you it's time to rest it you know is unwell and you need to
最严厉的批评者。所以我想到了我会对经历这一切的朋友表现出的同情和关怀。如果，你知道的，比如我最好的朋友艾伦对我说，哦天哪，这很有趣，因为她昨天刚给我打过电话，她感染了新冠。所以我其实有机会和别人进行这样一次对话，一次我本该对自己进行的对话。她对我说，她说，我病得太重了，什么也做不了。我需要打扫房子。我们要有客人来。我需要打电话给公司请病假。但我觉得自己太懒了，我对她说的是，这太荒谬了，你没有任何理由觉得自己懒惰，你的身体在尖叫着让你休息，它在告诉你，是时候休息了，你知道你身体不舒服，你需要
really care for it and mend it otherwise this is just going to come back even stronger otherwise it's going to take more time for you to heal this was all these things that I was saying to her I was like you need to be kinder to yourself you need to be nicer to yourself this is me giving you permission to rest and to relax and to just get better. And I believed that fully. I was fully, I believe that fully. That's the only thing I can say about that. I was like, yes, Erin, my beautiful, darling, gorgeous, caring friend deserves to take a break.
好好照顾它并调养它，否则这只会卷土重来，变得更加严重，否则你需要花更多的时间来恢复，这些都是我对她说的话，我说，你需要对你自己好一点，你需要对自己温柔一点，这是我给你的允许，让你去休息，去放松，然后好起来。我完全相信这一点。我完全，我完全相信这一点。这就是我对此唯一能说的。我当时想，是的，艾伦，我美丽、亲爱、华丽、体贴的朋友值得休息。
How come I don't? How come I cannot apply that same compassion and that same narrative to myself? I think it goes beyond just our inner critic and how loud they are. And more so towards this concept of like the spotlight effect. And the spotlight effect essentially says that our flaws, our perceived failures, our perceived laziness, everything that we see is wrong or bad about ourselves. That is so much more visible to us. Whereas when we look at our friends, we don't see those things about themselves that they don't like.
为什么我不能？为什么我不能把同样的同情和同样的叙事应用到我自己身上？我认为这不仅超越了我们内心的批评者以及他们的声音有多大，更多的是走向了聚光灯效应这个概念。聚光灯效应本质上是说，我们的缺点、我们意识到的失败、我们意识到的懒惰，我们认为自己身上不对或不好的每一件事。对我们自己来说，这些要明显得多。然而，当我们看着朋友时，我们看不到他们身上那些他们不喜欢的事情。
We don't see the reasons that they believe they deserve to be criticized. We don't see the things that we see about ourselves because they're hidden in their own internal worlds. So when we have the option or the choice to display empathy to us, we're seeing the scales as a lot more tipped to all the ways that we're failing and all the reasons we don't deserve a break, whereas our friends, our family, the people we love, they do because they're not as lazy as us. They're not as unproductive. They're not as bad. They are more worth the rest and the relaxation and the empathy and the kindness. So it's a bit of a disease, honestly. I think. that it's something that was really important for me to honestly see in real time was the
我们看不到他们认为自己应该受到批评的理由。我们看不到我们在自己身上看到的东西，因为它们隐藏在他们自己的内心世界里。所以当我们有选择去对自己表达同情时，我们会觉得天平更加倾向于我们失败的所有方式以及我们不值得休息的所有理由，而我们的朋友、我们的家人、我们所爱的人，他们值得，因为他们没有我们那么懒。他们没有那么低产。他们没有那么糟糕。他们更值得休息、放松、同情和善良。所以说实话，这有点像一种病。我认为。对我来说，在实时中真正看到这一点非常重要，那就是
difference and the distinction between the conversations I was having with myself about taking care of my body versus the conversations I was having with somebody that I truly love and who I really care about. So that is one factor of it. I think the other thing that I need to better recognize and get better at doing is also just like finishing my day when a task is done. I think I have this like serious problem where yes, I may have done everything that I actually wanted to do on my to do list. But I'm like, well, maybe the reason that I did everything was because I actually didn't push myself enough. Maybe I could have had the capacity to do more. So it's like a lose, lose situation. Either I don't do everything that I need to do or I do everything that I need to do.
我对自己身体照顾的对话与我同我真正爱的人以及我真正在乎的人之间的对话之间的区别和不同。所以这是其中的一个因素。我认为我需要更好地认识并做得更好的另一件事是，当任务完成时，也就结束了我的一天。我想我有一个很严重的问题，那就是，是的，我可能已经完成了待办事项清单上我真正想做的一切。但我想，好吧，也许我做了所有事情的原因是我实际上没有给自己足够压力。也许我有能力做更多的事。所以这是一个双输的局面。要么我没有做完我需要做的一切，要么我做完了我需要做的一切。
And that's just an opportunity for me to just pile on more or to believe that I've underestimated my ability during that day or my time. So yeah, it's a bit of a maze. I think that the things that I really need to do moving forward is like, okay, let's focus on just doing a couple of things each day and doing them really well because I think that that also keeps my attention on what I really need to do rather than feeling caught up in like the guilt spiral that just creates panic and worry that I'm not going to get things done. And so I kind of half-assed them. So that's something I really need to to prioritize and just like finishing when the task is done like if i did what i needed to do why do i need to do next week's to do list why do i need to start on tomorrow's to do list like it's just
而这对我来说只是一个机会，让我堆积更多的事情，或者相信我低估了那天自己的能力或时间。所以，是的，这有点像一个迷宫。我认为我接下来真正需要做的事情是，好吧，让我们专注于每天只做几件事情，并且把它们做得非常好，因为我认为这也让我的注意力集中在我真正需要做的事情上，而不是陷入内疚的漩涡中，那种漩涡只会制造恐慌和担忧，担心我无法完成事情。所以我有点敷衍了事。所以这是我真正需要优先考虑的事情，当任务完成时就结束，就像如果我做了我需要做的事情，为什么我还要去做下周的待办事项清单？为什么我要开始做明天的待办事项清单？这就像
i think at that point you're asking for an endless list of things that need to be completed that never ends and you're asking for a situation in which you just genuinely never know when to stop like what what's the end for that because if it's not getting sick what like when do you stop if you don't stop when you're sick, if you don't stop on vacation, if you don't stop when the task is done, it's kind of like you're in this cycle until death. And that is not necessarily the way that I'm planning on living my life. So that's been my first revelation as of recently that I am needing to address my toxic productivity. Not that I apply it to others, just that I apply it to myself and find a healthier relationship and, you know, balance with my work and my need to
我想在那一刻，你是在要求一个永远也做不完的、需要完成的事情的无休止的清单，你是在要求这样一种情况，那就是你真的永远不知道什么时候该停下来，因为这到底有什么终点？如果不是生病，什么——什么时候你才停下来？如果你生病了不停下来，如果你在度假时不停下来，如果在任务完成时不停下来，这就有点像你陷入了这个死循环。而这不一定是我计划中的生活方式。所以这是我最近的第一个启示，我需要解决我的有毒生产力。不是把它强加给别人，而是把它强加给我自己，并与我的工作以及我
actually be a human and sustain the other parts of me. It's been a big wake-up call as of recent, but there are some other really positive things going on in my life that I want to share with you and we're going to talk about them and kind of lighten the load, lighten the mood a little bit after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
真正作为一个人类并维持我生命其他部分的需求找到一种更健康的 رابطه（关系，此处用中文语境）和平衡。这最近是一个很大的警钟，但我的生活中还有其他一些非常积极的事情我想与你们分享，在这个短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论这些事情，并稍微轻松一下气氛。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”，即在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在“Look Back at it”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集马丁·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时可以谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
欢迎来到我的新播客《Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《Hard Way》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
搜索《Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试做了一次手脚。这需要一支由互联网侦探组成的军队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。吉尔斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I want to give you guys like a little personal update around like my living situation and how things have changed there, a little love life update and then a general update around the next six months. So the biggest thing is that I've finished my book, which is like insane. If you are considering writing a book, nonfiction, fiction, fiction, poetry, whatever it is, I could not, could not express this more. You really should do it.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我想向你们提供一点关于我的生活状况以及那里的情况如何改变的个人最新消息，一点爱情生活的最新消息，然后是关于未来六个月的总体最新消息。所以最大的事情是我完成了我的书，这简直太疯狂了。如果你正在考虑写一本书，非虚构、虚构、小说、诗歌，无论是什么，我简直无法，无法更多地表达这一点。你真的应该这样做。
but the other part of that is that it's going to be really, really hard. Because like the average manuscript is like 80,000 words, which is ridiculous, like absolutely insane when you think about it. That is almost the size of like a PhD thesis. It's like eight times the size of a master's thesis. So pretty intense. That's been really like on my mind in my life taking up a lot of my time recently. The other thing is that I now live alone, which is incredible.
但另一部分是，这将是非常非常艰难的。因为像平均手稿大约是80,000字，这很荒谬，当你想到它时绝对疯狂。这几乎相当于一个博士论文的规模。它大约是一个硕士论文规模的八倍。所以相当激烈。这一直在我的脑海里，最近占据了我大量的时间。另一件事是我现在一个人住，这太不可思议了。
and possibly one of the best decisions I have ever made. I lived with roommates for the last seven years. Like since I was 17 when I moved out of home, I've lived with other people and having other people around. And as somebody who I think has quite an odd, strange relationship with like loneliness, it always felt like until I moved in with a partner, I needed to live with other people because I couldn't like imagine the silence of being alone. Turns out, it is not as hard as I thought it would be. It's actually super peaceful and super fulfilling.
这可能是我做过的最好的决定之一。在过去的七年里，我和室友一起住。就像我17岁离开家搬出来以后，我就和别人一起生活，身边总是有其他人。作为一个我认为对孤独有相当奇怪、奇特关系的人，总觉得在和一个伴侣同居之前，我需要和别人一起住，因为我无法想象一个人呆着的寂静。事实证明，这并没有我想象的那么难。实际上超级平静，也超级充实。
I got a record player, which I think really helped because I love being out of playing music. When no one's home, I think it feels the silence. But the other component of it is that you just get to do whatever the hell you want with your own space. You know, you get to have your friends over and bring like the mattress out into the living room. you get to leave the kitchen as messy or as clean as you want it. You get to take the bins out when you would like. If something isn't done, it's on you. There's not this bubbling resentment towards somebody else.
我买了一台唱片机，我觉得这真的很有帮助，因为我喜欢放音乐。当家里没人的时候，我觉得它能填补安静。但另一部分原因是，你可以对自己的空间做任何你想做的事。你知道的，你可以邀请朋友来家里，把床垫搬到客厅里。你可以把厨房弄得乱七八糟，或者打扫得一尘不染。你想什么时候倒垃圾就什么时候倒。如果有什么事情没做完，那也是你自己的事。不会对别人产生那种积压的不满情绪。
So I freaking love it. I absolutely love it. I can't imagine. I really am thinking back to how I lived with other people for so long. I used to live with really good friends of mine and I love them so much. That was amazing. I think the change happens when you start to live with strangers though and it's kind of like, well, you know, you just don't have that same connection that makes it feel worthwhile.
所以我超级喜欢。我真的太喜欢了。我简直无法想象。我真的在回想自己以前怎么能和别人合租那么久。我以前和很好的朋友合租过，我非常爱他们。那段经历很棒。不过我想，当你开始和陌生人合租时，改变就发生了，那种感觉就像是，你知道的，你们没有那种能让这一切觉得值得的深厚联系。
And I had the opportunity to move out by myself to like a little cottage house. I was about to say where I live, probably not smart, but yeah, to like this little cottage house in like Sydney. And I just got like the most amazing deal. I really cannot express it. At the time I was like, actually, I'm going to. it clarify. I was like, yeah, I've got the most amazing deal. Like, this is so affordable. How is this house so cheap? I'll tell you why the house is so cheap. Number one, it doesn't have air conditioning or like any form of heating and the windows are super, super thin. The bedroom is like
而我当时有机会自己搬出去，住进一栋小别墅。我本来想说我住在哪里，可能不太明智，不过是的，就是悉尼的一栋小别墅。我真的谈到了一笔超棒的租房交易。我简直无法表达。当时我就想，实际上，我要澄清一下。我当时就想，对啊，我谈到了一笔最棒的交易。这房租太便宜了。这房子怎么这么便宜？我来告诉你为什么这房子这么便宜。第一，它没有空调，也没有任何形式的暖气，而且窗户超级超级薄。卧室就在
right onto the street, which is like kind of a vibe because you can hear every single person's conversations. But it also means that the house is freezing cold and the bathroom. the windows in the bathroom are like those pained kind of windows that like they'll be like six and they'll like open up do you know what I'm talking about it's like oh my gosh I really wish I could show you a photo but like yeah it's kind of like those pained windows that have like slats and they basically they shouldn't be in a bathroom especially the ones that are this old because they don't close all the way and some of them are like cracked so it means that anytime you go in there during winter, which it is now, winter in Australia, it's like freezing cold.
紧挨着街道的地方，这其实还挺有氛围感的，因为你能听到每个人的对话。但这也就意味着房子冷得像冰窖，而且浴室里的窗户是那种老式的木框玻璃窗，大概有六块，可以打开那种，你知道我在说什么吗？天哪，我真希望能给你们看张照片，但就是那种百叶窗式的窗户，基本上它们就不应该出现在浴室里，尤其是这么旧的窗户，因为它们根本关不严，有的还裂了。这就意味着，任何时候你冬天进浴室——现在正是澳洲的冬天——里面都冷得要命。
Probably not if you're probably not freezing if you live in the US or like Canada or someplace where it snows. Like I am still living in Sydney. The coldest it gets is like 15 degrees Celsius. So I can't complain too much. But yeah, that's the other reason why this house is cheap. And the final reason is that you can hear everything that the neighbors are doing and they can hear everything that you're doing, which I don't mind, but my next door neighbor is cranky and I was having like a game's like a board game night with like four of my close friends only two of us were drinking out of the five of us and it wasn't like we were like listen we're not doing like fireball shots we're not playing like loud music on the TV we are sitting at the kitchen
如果你住在美国、加拿大或下雪的地方，可能就不会觉得那么冷了。毕竟我还住在悉尼。最冷的时候也就15摄氏度左右。所以我不能抱怨太多。不过，这就是这房子便宜的另一个原因。最后一个原因就是，你能听到邻居们在干什么，他们也能听到你在干什么。这倒没什么，但我隔壁的邻居脾气很暴躁。当时我在和四个密友玩桌游之夜，我们五个人里只有两个人在喝酒，而且我们也不是在喝烈酒，也没有把电视声音开得很大，我们只是坐在厨房
table playing herd mentality which is an amazing board game if you haven't heard of it and she like comes over and is like basically threatens to like call the police on us and is like you are being a nuisance bear in mind it is 945 on a Saturday night with five women in their 20s eating pasta playing a board game this is not a rager and so yeah now we're in this like kind of tug of war where she oh my god also anytime I leave my front door open because I like to have like a breeze coming through she'll i like see her walk past and like stare in with her little dogs and it is super strange. I'm like, yep, I still live here. Don't worry. I'm not going anywhere. So that's one thing. Final thing, it's under a flight path. Probably should have said that
桌子旁玩《从众心理》（Herd mentality）——如果你没听说过的话，这是一款非常棒的桌游——然后她就走过来，基本上威胁要报警，说我们是个讨厌鬼。提醒一下，当时是周六晚上九点四十五分，五个二十多岁的女性在吃着意面玩桌游，这根本不是什么狂欢派对。所以，是的，现在我们陷入了一种拉锯战，每当我把前门打开想让微风吹进来时，我就能看到她走过去，带着她的小狗往里窥视，这真的太诡异了。我在想，是的，我还住在这里。别担心，我哪儿也不去。这就是其中一件事。最后一件事，它在航线下。我本该最先说这个的
first as somebody who does like audio work for their like profession. Yeah, it's required a few adaptations to my life because I really cannot express how loud this is. It is like a, it is like full on like Boeing 777s or whatever. huge cargo planes like flying so close to my house that I can see the screws on the bottom of the plane. It is something you get used to though. So listen, I thought I was getting a good deal. It still is a good deal and I'm still so happy. But this is your reminder that if something seems a little bit too good to be true, you should definitely check in on that. Because for what I'm playing, I definitely think that, yeah, I'm getting what I'm, I'm getting what I'm paying in terms of the
作为一个把音频工作当作职业的人来说。是的，这需要我的生活做出一些调整，因为我真的无法形容这里有多吵。这就像是一架波音777或者别的什么飞机，巨大的货机从我家头顶飞过，飞得那么近，我都能看清飞机底部的螺丝。不过这也是可以习惯的。所以听着，我以为我捡了个便宜。它确实还是个便宜，而且我也还是很开心。但这也提醒你，如果某件事看起来好得有些不真实，你绝对应该去核实一下。因为就我付的房租而言，我觉得，是的，我得到的正是
faultiness of this place and the downsides. Moving on to a little love update, honestly, all positive on this front. I feel like you guys have really been following along with this relationship. Obviously, when I started this podcast, I was like devastated and heartbroken from my last relationship ending. And then, you know, throughout the course of doing the show, I had my heartbroken again in a situation ship. And then a year ago, I came on and was like, oh my God, surprise, surprise. I've met somebody. And what the heck? It's going really well. And this is really healthy and he's a really nice person. And I don't feel insecure at all. What is happening? What is going on? And yeah, we celebrated our one year last week, which is like absolutely wild because
这个地方的缺陷和坏处。接下来是一个小小的感情更新，说实话，在这方面全都是好消息。我觉得大家真的是一路见证了这段感情。显然，刚开始做这个播客时，上一段感情的结束让我感到崩溃和心碎。然后呢，在这个节目的制作过程中，我在一段没有名分的暧昧关系里再次心碎了。再然后，一年前，我来到节目里说：“天哪，惊喜吧。我遇到某人了。”而且，怎么回事？进展非常顺利。这是一段非常健康的感情，他是个非常好的人。我一点也不觉得没有安全感。这是怎么了？发生了什么？然后，是的，我们上周庆祝了一周年，这简直太疯狂了，因为
I still remember sitting down for that life update episode and being like, I've met this really nice guy and I really hope that it works but yeah he's we're doing amazing I don't like to speak about him too much because he has like a like real big boy job if that's even like the way of saying it like he's a lawyer and has like real clients and you know it just feels a lot more consequential and like a lot more serious and I don't want to like bring him on as much and like talk about his life as much in case it like interrupts with what he's doing but he doesn't really seem to mind so shout out to the love of my life. He is so sweet. This is your reminder to freaking wait for the right person and you will know it when you see it and when you feel it.
我还记得自己坐下来录制那期生活更新节目时，说：“我遇到了这个非常好的男生，我真的很希望我们能成。”但真的，我们现在进展太棒了。我不太想过多谈论他，因为他有一份真正的高薪大企业工作，如果可以这么说的话——他是个律师，有很多真正的客户，你知道的，这感觉更重要，也更严肃，我不想过多地把他带入节目，过多地谈论他的生活，万一打扰到他的工作就不好了。但他其实并不介意，所以向我生命中的挚爱致敬。他太温柔了。这也提醒大家，一定要耐心等待那个对的人，当你看到他、感受到他时，你自然就会知道。
Like it's, I don't know. I hate all those cliches. I'm so sorry to be that person that I hated when I was single who was like when you know you'll know. But like, fuck, it's really true. It's really true. And as for like a more general life update, as I'm recording this, I'm literally leaving for London in tomorrow. Tomorrow. I'm living for London at like 12 p.m. tomorrow. My stomach kind of dropped when I said that.
就好像是，我不知道。我讨厌所有这些陈词滥调。非常抱歉成为那种我以前单身时最讨厌的人——就是那种说什么“当你懂了自然就懂了”的人。但是，操，这真的是真的。真的是真的。至于更广泛的生活更新，当我录制这段音频时，我明天就要启程去伦敦了。明天。我明天中午左右就要动身去伦敦了。我说出这句话的时候，胃猛地往下沉了一下。
I'm still like deathly afraid of planes. So we'll see how that one works out. I'll be fine. It is a long flight from Australia though. So if you're like listening from the UK, please hit me up if you've ever done the flight to Australia because you will know how like heinous it is. It's like 24 hours on a plane.
我还是对飞机有一种致命的恐惧。所以我们看看这次会怎么样吧。我会没事的。不过从澳大利亚飞过去确实是一场漫长的飞行。所以如果你是从英国在收听的话，如果你曾经坐过飞往澳大利亚的航班，请联系我，因为你懂的，那有多惨烈。在飞机上要待足足24个小时。
and the jet lag is just like I'm not looking forward to it. But I am looking forward to traveling around London. I'm going to Bristol as well for an exciting launch with somebody who lives in Bristol. That's all I'm going to say on that. Probably should have announced that before I announced my book that doesn't come out for a year, but nonetheless. I'm going to Bristol. I'm going to Paris for three days. One of my best friends from uni is living there as an actor.
而且时差简直——我真的一点也不期待。不过我很期待在伦敦四处游玩。我还要去布里斯托，和一个住在布里斯托的人一起参与一个激动人心的发布活动。关于这个我只能说这么多了。我大概应该在我那个要一年后才出版的书官宣之前宣布这个的，不过不管怎样。我要去布里斯托。我要去巴黎呆三天。我大学最好的朋友之一现在是一名演员，正住在那里。
insane the places that people go. So I'm just super excited. I'm super excited to, I think that was also like some of the pressure behind why I was like, I need to get better. You know, this sickness cannot ruin this for me. Like I've spent the last months and months like working so hard. I want to break when I'm overseas. I think it's looking up. It looks like I'm going to have a really good time. So if you're in the UK, please like also message me with suggestions. I feel like every time I go to London, I do like the same 10 things. And I, need to diversify the experience because when people come and visit me in Newtown and in Sydney, I'm always like, no, no, no, we're not going there. I'm going to show you the hidden spots.
人们去的地方真是疯狂。所以我超级兴奋。我超级兴奋去——我觉得这也是为什么我当时有那种压力的原因，我当时想：“我必须好起来。这场病绝不能毁了这一切。”过去的好几个月里我一直在拼命工作。我希望在海外的时候能好好放松一下。我觉得事情正在变好。看起来我会玩得很开心。所以如果你在英国，请也给我发消息提提建议。我觉得每次去伦敦我都只会做同样的那10件事。我需要让体验多元化，因为每当人们来纽敦和悉尼探望我时，我总是说：“不，不，不，我们不去那里。我要带你去那些隐藏的宝藏地点。”
And they have a great time. So I need like a tour guide for me in like in Hackney in Camden, in London. So please send me your suggestions. And thank you for listening this far to this rambly episode, this life update around my recent, I guess like emotional mental health epiphanies to do with productivity, but also just it's nice that you care about what's going on in my life and not just the psychology and the science of everybody else's lives. So thank you so much for listening, for making it this far. Make sure that you are following along on Instagram at that psychology podcast. If you have anything you want to share, if you have an episode suggestion, you know I love to hear them. So many episodes coming up are suggestions from the listeners. So
他们都会玩得很开心。所以我需要一个导游，带我在伦敦的哈克尼和卡姆登逛逛。所以请把你们的建议发给我。谢谢你们听了这么久我这期东拉西扯的节目，这期关于我最近对生产力产生的情感和心理健康感悟的生活更新，不过大家关心我生活中发生的事情，而不仅仅是关心别人生活的心理学和科学，这真的很暖心。所以非常感谢大家的收听，能听到这里。记得在Instagram上关注@thatpsychologygpodcast。如果你有什么想分享的，或者有什么节目建议，你知道我最喜欢听了。很多即将播出的节目都来自听众的建议。所以
we see every single one of them and it all goes into this huge master list that I love to sift through and sift through and sift through and have a look at your amazing ideas because you are so creative and have such good perspectives on your 20s and your lives. Make sure you're following along as well with the podcast. Hit follow on Apple Podcasts on Spotify. Leave a five-star review. I read them all. if you feel cool to do so, I would love to see some positive feedback or feedback of any kind. And thank you so much for listening and for following along. We will be back on Friday with another episode. Until then, stay safe.
我们看到了每一条建议，它们都汇集到了这个庞大的总清单里，我非常喜欢一遍又一遍地翻看、筛选，看看你们那些绝妙的点子，因为你们真的太有创意了，对二十多岁的生活有着如此独到且精彩的视角。确保你们也关注了这个播客。在苹果播客和Spotify上点击关注。留下五星好评。我都会读的。如果你愿意的话，我很乐意看到一些正面的反馈或任何形式的反馈。非常感谢你们的收听和支持。我们周五会带着另一期节目回归。在此之前，注意安全。
Be kind to yourself and we will talk soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
善待自己，我们很快就会再聊。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并尝试和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed
比如Mark Lamont Hill聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真的是疯狂的一年。对于黑人来说，我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kier Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目聚焦黑男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全但却必须进行的坦诚对话，而你的对话对象是一位懂行的执业
professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
专业人士。有多少男人披着盔甲。它向世界信号暗示：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。您曾两次做过这项特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。